America our prayers have been answered
alec baldwin says if he ran for
president he'd win if I ran I would win
you would I would absolutely win 1,000%
why don't you run for president as
Donald Trump that way everyone will have
everything for president I would win
hands down I would because you would be
the funniest most exciting what are you
crazy can't Wayne yes this friends is
the election this country needs and the
media deserves could you ask for a
better matchup Donald Trump and a guy
who makes a living as Donald Trump and
although he's never run a business he
has played someone who has did anyone
see boss baby that's a great film I kid
Baldwin he's way more than an
impersonator
he's an actor and he's got more in
common with Trump that he thinks he's a
famous blustering ego driven New Yorker
and he cares hopefully enough to appoint
Sean Penn as his running mate great but
here's the big point Alec and I know
you're watching you hate this president
and you fear where the country is headed
and it makes it hard to remember your
lines
you see what it does to your friends of
course I want to punch him in the face
[Applause]
an awful lot about blowing up the White
House they're a mess all of your friends
are destroying themselves so you've got
a run you've got to do it for them
before they lose it completely if you
feel that strongly about stopping Trump
why stay on the sidelines like a coward
and if not you then who have you seen
the Democrats a bunch of hopeless stiffs
and Oprah but you you're the only hope
your party has there's no one better
that's why I'm starting the draft Alec
2020 campaign don't have a little button
there it is ha I invite viewers to join
let's make him the Democratic nominee
because Alec you've taken your shots
time to settle this once and for all the
only reason why you won't is because
you're scared of losing but what did you
just say before if I ran
president I would win hands down that
would be so what's keeping you all right
Dana this is exactly what we need
somebody from Hollywood run yes and
settle this question and if people if he
is such a patriot and believes in his
heart that Trump is evil he's the man I
stopped him absolutely
hashtag 20/20 Alec Baldwin why come on
you know he's he's an entertainer he had
a TV show
he's like Trump this is what the
Democrats need you ever see that film
idiocracy yes that's my baby Bob so now
we're gonna have two people totally
unqualified we the Democrats will say
well the Republican was unqualified just
a celebrity just a TV guy knows nothing
and he goes off and he runs and he won
so Alec Baldwin says hey I'm a better
entertainer I'm a better actor so I can
beat him hands down I mean the only he
said he thinks that Trump will fire
Muller he said he thinks that Trump just
said to Kim at the summit I'll just say
you're gonna Dinu clear eyes cuz I need
that tomorrow you like so I mean it's
like an absurdity I mean it's like a
joke it's like what the thing is we're
all living through it yes I think I
could see a ticket Kimberly yes I could
see it and he is the face of the
resistance I mean he plays Trump every
Saturday yes you're saying you know
saddle up yes what do you think your
money where your mouth is solutely and
when you look at the cast of characters
of alternatives in this very car who are
you gonna have I mean when you think
about I mean would Sean Penn beyond the
lead of that ticket or balls win who
would you have you know besides I mean
the only one actually probably is like
Oprah Winfrey yeah she would be good and
normal but other than that outlaw would
be absolutely entertaining Jesse yes
what can you say I would say we finally
found a candidate that hates reporters
more than Trump punched reporters yes
yes match their cameras Trump hasn't
even done that I listened to the
interview live I love Howard bababooey
and Howard was very tough and very fair
he didn't really take a side but this
guy's obsessed with Trump he was one
with Howard for an hour and half kept
bringing the conversation back to Muller
he thinks they're these secret
apprentice tapes that are long-lost that
show Trump saying all this stuff but I
do think and just looking at him he
looks like a president I actually kind
of liked him when
look at Baldwin he loved us he did joke
that if you did run for president he'd
spend the entire summer in the Hamptons
yeah he's not running because he said
his wife wouldn't be with what about the
Hamptons
Trump has executive time he spends the
machina and the in the White House Red
Room the similarities he hosts TV shows
like our president he's a brash New
Yorker hair known among the ladies for
hate hair huge ego and a colorful past I
I just don't know why if you know a
hundred percent or a thousand percent
that you can win then Ron didn't run I
mean what is it Alec I know he watches
this show I heard that this is his
favorite show yeah and I'm his favorite
host okay I heard that I can tell yes
yes